for me it's really emotional being here
and the one thing that I can't convey on
video is the smell
I'm in the main lecture theater in the
university in Turin where the famous
Italian chemical writer primo levy was a
student prima Lavery was the author of
the book the periodic table and I'm
sitting here possibly in the seat that
he sat in and I'm looking at the
periodic table and this periodic table
was put up in 1997 that's 13 years ago
on the tenth anniversary of his death as
a memorial to him
primo la vie was a Jewish chemist he was
a student here and then because of the
racial laws in fascist times in Italy he
was sent off to work in some fairly
remote chemical work in near Milan and
then after that he joined the partisans
fighting against the Germans quite an
incompetent band I think and he was
captured and was sent to the death camps
in Auschwitz and there and this is
really remarkable he survived because he
was a chemist the Germans during the
Second World War were running out of
rubber for the tires for the military
vehicles and so they set up a synthetic
rubber factory next to the death camp
but they had no chemists so they asked
among the prisoners if there are any
people who were chemists and there was
prima la vie
in absolute terrible condition starving
in prison uniform he had to sit a
chemistry exam to see if he really knew
chemistry and then he was allowed to
work in this lab which was warm and he
could swear when everybody else was
freezing in the dreadful conditions of
the winter from 1943 to 44 when he came
back to Turin Primo Lavery started to
work in a varnish factory making paints
and varnish and for many people part of
his greatness is the way he wrote about
chemistry writing about
mystery writing about the joys of
turning one chemical into another of the
mysteries making it sound so much more
like the alchemy it is rather than the
precise science of the textbooks
he spoke of what chemists feel like when
they're doing it so this is the lab the
undergraduate lab where primo Lavery was
a student you can imagine him in here
with a group of he talks about other
students all in their lab coats all
wearing white coats except the
extroverts who wear colored ones and he
talks about how some of them baked cakes
out of starch and other chemicals just
like Sam has done in some of our videos
but they were rather more
entrepreneurial and sold these at tea
time for people to eat having cooked
them in this ovens that they're used for
drying their chemical samples for me
it's really emotional being here and the
one thing that I can't convey on video
is the smell there's a wonderful smell
of chemicals in here quite different
from the smells that we get in modern
labs and I hope even when they refurbish
this lab they're just about to start
work here that perhaps somehow the smell
will survive the smell of almost a
century of chemists doing chemistry here
you can feel the atmosphere and the
smell is just wonderful he was not a
great chemist in a way this is why he's
so great he didn't make special
discoveries but he represents all the
chemists the thousands of chemists who
worked so hard doing chemistry but whose
voices are never heard